good morning everybody and welcome to
this meeting of mid-suffolk district
council cabinet
i'm councillor susie morley leader of
mid-south district council and i am
chairing this meeting today
may i remind you of some domestic
arrangements
please ensure that you maintain social
distancing from all other persons whilst
in the chamber and in the communal areas
please ensure that you wear a face
covering at all times unless you are
sitting down
or if you exempt from doing so and that
you lose
use the hand sanitizer and wipes
provided
please ensure that microphones are
turned off when not in use
please do not interrupt other speakers
or hold separate conversations whilst
others are speaking
if you are attending the meeting to
speak and persistently interrupt the
meeting you may be asked to leave
please ensure your mobile phones are on
silent or switched off
and finally we will be using e-voting
for this meeting on the modern.gov app
so please could all members make sure
they are logged in and ready to use the
app
i would like to remind everyone present
that this meeting will be broadcast live
to the internet and will be capable of
repeated viewing
the whole of the meeting will be filmed
except where there are confidential or
exempt items
if you make a representation to the
meeting you will be deemed by the
council to have consented to being
filmed
by entering this meeting as a speaker
you are also consenting to being
recorded by the council and to the
possible use of those images and sound
recordings for webcasting
and or training purposes
the council members of the public and
the press may record film photograph or
broadcast this meeting when the public
and the press are not lawfully excluded
i'm now going to move to the agenda
please item 1 apologies for absence
thank you chair we have apologies from
councillor gould
thank you very much
item two to receive declarations of
pecuniary and non-pecuniary interest by
members are there any to declare
no thank you
item three
is mca
21
33
and this is to confirm the minutes of
the cabinet meeting held on the 6th of
december 2022.
are there any points of accuracy of the
minutes
could i have a proposal please
counselor heading thank you and a
seconder councillor flatman thank you
the governance officer will now conduct
the vote
thank you chair members that vote is now
in progress in your app
thank you members chair that's eight
votes for that you know
thank you very much
item four to receive notifications of
petitions in accordance with the
council's petition scheme
then received
item five questions by councillors
not received
thank you
item six
is matters referred by the overview and
scrutiny or joint audit and standards
committee
and i now invite the chair of the
overview and scrutiny committee
councillor willem
to present the recommendations from the
overview and scrutiny committee
council thank you chair
yeah
um
mitzvah overview of scrutiny considered
the giraffe general fund
budget and the four year outlook
and they've asked that the cabinet
member for finance have regard to the
detailed comments
that are set out
in the in the appendix
before finalizing his budget
and presenting it to council
those comments are set up on pages 13
and 14 and i'm assuming that i don't
need to refer to them anymore because
cabinet will have read them
detailed comments were made in respect
to a couple of things
one was concern over staffing and
vacancies
and
the other was over the very high level
of reserves especially the plan to put
another 3.35 million pounds into
reserves
when
members of the committee felt that this
ought to be spent on services for our
communities
a more general concern
is around the timing of the scrutiny of
budgets
members consider that there is greater
value in reviewing the budget process
and the assumptions made in developing a
detailed budget
this would allow a more strategic
approach to scrutinizing the budget
a further concern expressed by committee
was the need to ensure financial
scrutiny of all aspects of the council's
work
and also there is currently a lack of
clarity around the terms of reference of
the overview of scrutiny committee and
the audit and standards committee
and the monitoring officer
and uh the constitutional working group
have been asked to look into this thank
you chair
thank you
do you want me to go straight on to the
um no i'll take questions on this one
first anybody have any questions
no
okay thank you council we'll have to
continue
oh
sorry sorry counselor
um thank you chair if i may not ask a
question i just wondered if the um
and it's probably for yourself chair as
leader rather than the overview and
scrutiny chair um with regards to the
questions need to be addressed to
councillor okay i'll address them
in terms of the budget um
the future involvement earlier
involvement with the budget
would this
be able to consider the involvement of
the community in setting the budget
especially on the choices available for
that community and get them more
involved in the budget setting process
please and secondly it's noted that um
councillor whitehead had said he
that the use of the three and a half
million would be considered by um
cabinet views in the community and i
just wondered when that was going to be
considered thank you very much chair
uh thank you for the question
yes um
what the overview security committee
would like to do would be to have a
really thorough look at the budget
process
um and obviously we haven't looked into
how we would do that but certainly one
of the aspects
would be to
to consider how there could be some
community involvement
in drawing up the the
the the budget for the next year thank
you
thank you
we are intending consulting on
uh
more widely on the budget next year
without our
residents
sorry chad i didn't hear a word that you
said then sorry
i said that we are intending
uh consulting more widely
next year and that will take place next
week and your recommendations are noted
thank you thank you well that's good to
hear because that's something that we
that overview and scrutiny can work with
um
finance people to to
consider how that can best be done thank
you
um thank you if you can move on to the
hr
certainly yeah
um
yeah a number of detailed questions
we're asking members made a a number of
comments
uh on the budget and the four-year
outlook and these are again these are
contained in an appendix so i'm assuming
that they have all been read
um there are a couple of concerns one
was the um
the volume of planned maintenance work
which will not be completed by the end
of the current municipal year
resulting in a large carryover adding to
the volume of work planned for next
financial year
concern was also expressed around the
large increase in housing rents at a
time of high increases in the cost of
any cost of energy and so on
committee asked that information be
provided to the council meeting later
this month comparing the level of rent
proposed with levels of council house
rents
which are levied by
other authorities
again happy to answer any questions
cabinet members have any questions for
councillor welling
no thank you councillor wellam your
recommendations are included
item seven is the forthcoming decisions
list does anybody have any
comments on that
item eight
mca
21-34
is the general fund budget for 2022-23
and a four year outlook
i'll now invite the cabinet member for
finance to introduce his report thank
you
thank you madam chairman
for my first report today i'd like to
introduce the general fund budget 2223
and four-year outlook report mca 2134
which starts on page 21 of our pack
over the past few years we've delivered
outer significantly ahead of budget
and whilst one driver of that has been
additional income we've also
acknowledged that in building up the
budget department by department we've
perhaps led caution on to caution
so for this new budget 2223 managers
have been pushed
to use stretching but realistic
assumptions across both income and
expenditure
we anticipate an outer position
therefore being close to budget going
forward and that knowledge there is an
element of risk to this approach
we will of course continue to monitor
the position with our regular quarterly
reporting to cabinet
this budget has already been to all
member briefings group briefings and 12
years scrutiny and we welcome the
observations from the opium scrutiny
committee which are duly noted
as well as setting the bud as well as
setting the annual budget we do our best
to forecast a four-year outlook so we
can bring a longer term approach to
align our financial strategy
to our medium-term six corporate
strategic priorities
now at the risk of sounding like a
broken record we are not helped in this
approach by central government who for
the third year have provided only one
year of certainty in their local
government settlement
and furthermore with the settlement only
just being announced prior to christmas
when so much of the hard graft behind
our budget work is nearing completion
then surprise announcements like an
additional 971 000 of income
compared to what we were assuming
almost invariably needs first to be put
into reserves before any detailed new
spending plans for them can be
established
still it would be churlish not to
welcome this additional money
chart 4 at paragraph 4.27 in the report
shows that the government grant
allocation is 749 000 pounds
higher in 2223 compared to 2122
including a very generous new homes
bonus settlement
now every year i believe bar none we've
closed off our accounts without ever
needing to use new homes bones to fund
our base services
now having a look back at budgets from
several years ago whilst
writing this introductory speech
i'm struck by our increasing use of
graphics in these reports and i hope
particularly that members this year
will find the many colorful pie charts
of income expenditure reserves useful
in putting the numerical information
into a more easy to understand visual
format
i'm struck particularly by the total
income chart
7 on page 40
where we see the council tax segment of
6.96 million
and the investment income of 4.631
million
this investment from the likes of cifco
is the equivalent of about 114 pounds
per bandy property
a lot of hard work over the years has
gone into developing these income
streams and it is one of the key drivers
behind our decision to freeze council
tax for the coming year
the tax base itself has also grown by
4.47 year-on-year which also assists a
great deal
now as a local authority we can't claim
to be unique there's no doubt in my mind
that we are a very favorable outlier in
the la universe when it comes to our
financial position
although we only set council tax for one
year at a time
our four-year outlook is based on there
being no increase in council tax precept
per dwelling over that entire period
but i must stress beyond march 23 that's
just a forecast not a promise
as i said earlier it's so difficult to
plan beyond a year when we have just a
one-year settlement from central
government
our four-year forecast shows each year
to be in surplus and our schedule
reserves shows the real potential
to
grow our ambitions beyond those first
four one billion pound pots of money
that we put aside in this current
financial year
to be spent over the coming months for
the benefit our residents in mid suffolk
now there's a lot of detail in this
budget report including several pages of
budget assumptions and risks
i won't go through those here but they
should be read to get a fuller
understanding of our revenue and
expenditure budget
there is another important budget
element within this report i refer of
course to capital
the details of that are tabulated
appendix say on page 48.
we have a large carry forward which is
primarily our very exciting gateway 14
project
and having got the hybrid planning
commission approval in 2021 it will now
be full steam ahead on that project
the other large capital projects relate
to mississippi growth housing and the
replacement of our refuge freighters
total capital spent 2223 is budgeted at
29 million and this includes the new
allocation of 9.6 million that
councillors will be asked to approve at
full council
recommendations in the report today is
that these general fund budget proposals
for 2223 and four-year outlook be
endorsed by cabinet to take full council
on the 24th of february
these proposals include a freeze on
mississippi elementary council tax where
the vandy precept remains 171.59
which works out at only 47 pence per day
for all the many valuable services we
provide
i'm pleased to move these
recommendations and we'll ask for a
second thank you jeff
thank you councillor whitehead do we
have a seconder
i'm happy to second the report chair
thank you councillor flatman
do we have any questions from cabinet
members
questions from anybody else
councillor eben
thank you very much chair and thank you
councillor whitehead for um for this and
thank you for everybody for working on
it um the
i've got a few questions just with
regards to the process and then one very
specific one
if i may um in setting this up you talk
about self-financing and not being
reliant on government funding although
we
i think it's about 17 of our funding
comes from government
um so is there a figure that you'd want
to
you know get down to as it were not
accept government funding
noting as well that you know that
you say we never used new homes bonus
um
secondly on the evaluation of
you know how we're putting a budget
together you talk about that being based
on increased social value but i
understand i'm not sure what we measure
and how we measure increase social value
so i'll be interested in that
and thirdly um at 4.13 you talk about
driving out inefficiencies and i just
wondered if you could give an example of
an inefficiency
and and how much you would expect to
save on that
and i've got one very specific question
if i may share that on the
business rates
i understand that last year we had
somewhat of a
a bonus from the branford substation in
in the millions um
[Music]
uh figure
and i just wondered is that included in
this business race and is that an
ongoing
amount and i appreciate that might be
quite specific to answer at this point
in time but i would
be interested to know if that's ongoing
or it was a one-off thank you very much
thank you um
okay um well in terms of um
government funding
we certainly welcome that i mean it's
money that would doubt find elsewhere
but um they you know in terms of the
other streams we do get an awful lot of
money in from our fees and charges
planning income building control and
many other areas such as garden waste
for example
as well as the
business rates we collect
and the council tax so
i think we could look at it in in the
whole
overall scheme which i think is why it's
useful sometimes to see these things in
colored pie charts but i can't give you
a definitive answer in terms of sort of
what percentage are we aiming for i
think we're just basically trying to
reduce our reliance and become more
self-sufficient uh with no sort of real
target
in mind but just basically a
direction of travel
um
i think
i think you mentioned us i think you
mentioned that we don't use new homes
bonus i think the reality is we don't
use those new homes bonus to
uh for our base services just because
although it's been going on 15 years we
always sort of felt that it's it's
government's gift to give or
government's gift to take away so we've
we've tried our best not to rely on that
a couple of years i think we've used
some money to produce a balanced budget
but then the out turns always been of
such an extent that we never actually
did use new homes bonus at all with and
in terms of getting our base budget but
so much of that has gone in over the
years into first a transformation fund
and then the growth efficiency fund
which has been used to
form enough projects for
to to benefit our community
communities
so that's my sort of thoughts on new
homes bonus
um in terms of how we
measure social value um i mean it's
something as an accountant it's always
puzzled me a bit where we talk about for
every pound spent we get 12 pound back
of social value and i'm probably a bit
of a cynic and i probably shouldn't be
but i don't if anyone or any officers
would perhaps come to my rescue in terms
of what their thoughts are in terms of
social value and measuring it
i can try and assist um
only from the perspective of we are
developing a social values framework so
that we can be very clear and try and
measure exactly as you describe um the
impact that we're having that is harder
by its very nature to measure because
it's it's qualitative not quantitative i
always have to think before i get those
the wrong way around um but there is
also conversations been happening both
through the suffolk health and
well-being board and also with suffolk
partners more widely because as you can
imagine what's good social value impact
for mid-suffolk isn't unique to
mid-suffolk it's also true of the wider
public sector so rather than doing these
things in isolation we're looking at
how we can do it together so that we can
have a single mechanism particularly for
the measuring aspect which i think would
help councillor whitehead to some degree
possibly with that cynicism but also
help with all of us to be able to be
clear how much we can stretch every
pound that we invest in our districts
um calvary burn also asked a question
about an example of
inefficiencies i think over the years we
have become more efficient and perhaps
becomes more difficult to sort of grasp
sort of up to the minute um
ideas on that i mean
one thing that just comes to mind is in
the old days when i used to turn up at
needham market to see an officer and
then find their way in hadley and
many officers spent their time moving
back and forth between hadley and
needham market that was a big
inefficiency that was um
that we um
got rid of by moving into endeavour
house as well as the sort of
the um um the climate inefficiencies of
that building with its single uh glazing
and uh ridiculously bad epc
um so that
that's my comment there
in terms of business rates the bradford
substation my understanding is once
something gets on the valuation list
it's there with a ratable value it's
a
a figure is applied to available value
each year so it's the sort of gift that
keeps on giving but um just in case i'm
not wrong there i'll just ask catherine
just to clarify that
what i've said is correct i think sorry
i see where nodding hedges the fact that
yes the the bradford substation was a
bonus for like the first year and it
keeps it's there
for good now well
i think that basically answers the
questions
so yes i was nodding my head that the
what councillor whitehead was saying was
correct in terms of the the business
rates and just to say i think there is
mention in the report that we have to do
a return um as at the end of january to
the government around business rates
which is called our ndr1 return
and we're just analyzing that to see if
there's any other impact from that in
terms of the business rates figures
cancer even i just come back thank you
so much for that councilwhitehead and
thank you catherine um if it'd be useful
i was wondering if we can ask whether
members can see the analysis of business
rates just so we know
get an idea of that and secondly if
social value is being developed and
obviously it wasn't used for this budget
although i mentioned it in the report
and whether we could be kept
we could be told when that's happening
and um
let us know about that thank you very
much
thank you
well councilman
thank you chair um yes i have a question
for councillor what had on on reserves
um
from what i can see we we we've got a
3.35 million
going into
the growth and efficiency fund which
will end up with a surplus of roughly
three and a half million at the end of
the
financial year um
and obviously a total reserve figure of
19 million there um
a couple of places in the report um
section 43 of the local government act
1992 is quoted where it says that the
council must have regard
to the level of reserves
so i want to ask if the if this
act places any restrictions on the level
of reserves that the council carries
um and also just further what is the
intention
for
the growth and efficiency fund what are
we going to spend that 3.5 million on
thank you
thank you
i'm not aware of any legislation that
limits lovely reserves i was looking at
one district council um a few days a few
days ago which appeared to have a 70
million pound reserve i'm not quite sure
how they managed to achieve that it
certainly puts ours into perspective 18
million
um but um
i
i think there's about 18 or 19
categories there in that table five with
reserves so
you know it is to spread out for
a number of reasons
um the graphing efficiency fund
by its very nature i mean it's supposed
to be there
any day
any
counsellor can suggest a project for its
use
any member of staff from
from top to bottom can sort of come
forward with ideas for its use and
we've changed it from transformation to
greater efficiency because basically so
much of it's come from growth
or efficiencies
and its purpose is not only to come to
bring money from that but then to use it
for future growth and efficiency so
i always hope that it will become a sort
of virtuous circle that money would come
in
um from growth efficiencies and then be
used to create further growth
efficiencies
but um
you know i
want to be totally clear that that money
is not there to
be determined at budget time it's there
for any kind of project
any time of year
thank you thank you councillor whitehead
um
did you have a
question
sorry a question or are you wanting to
start a debate
i had a question okay
um
john
actually my question is triggered by um
the question asked by councillor ebern
concerning
the brantford station um
we have um
an
nationally significant infrastructure
project just starting up near eye
progress power along with another
quite a large substation
we also have a number of
solar farms
growing up
in the district
how do we benefit financially from these
do they
pay business rates
you know what is the public benefit
cancer whitehead
i i'll start my answer but i shall
probably
look to catherine for a bit of a
guidance as well because i i don't claim
to be a business race expert the my
understanding is that things like the
progress power
station things like solar farms and even
and
the likes of potentially
valley ridge and our own gateway 14
development all of these will bring in
business rates because they'll all be
valued for business rating purposes
and and then the multiplier will be
applied to that and it'll be shared
between ourselves the county and central
government but i'd ask um
catherine just put perhaps a few more a
bit more meat on those
bones for me
i would invite catherine to come in on
this one thank you chair thank you
councillor whitehead um yeah in terms of
something like the the i substation that
obviously is a significant development
what happens is we report all of those
new developments through to the
valuation office and then the valuation
office determines
whether it might stay on what's called
the local list where we would gain some
benefit from it or if it's actually on
the central list if it's on the central
list then the government keeps all of
the business rates associated with it so
we're not clear at the moment with
something like the eye substation as to
which list that one is going to going to
fall on um in terms of things like the
solar farms
they are
as sort of green initiatives and we do
keep to get to keep more of the business
rates locally where we have things like
that and wind turbo turbines as well are
a couple of examples so those ones we do
get to keep more of the income locally
than would normally go past you know 50
across to the government
thank you may i have a just a follow-up
um
yes i mean something like the i
power plant which will as opposed to the
substation
um
that's quite a large item so i hope
we're doing our best to be able to
gain as much financial benefit from it
as as possible and um
it's it may be uh i'm not sure at the
moment it's the is it the only an
energy large energy project in the
district nsi
p in the in the district i think it may
be um
but um anyway i just if you could assure
us that you're we're doing our best to
benefit from such a large development
thank you
so now i'm going to move on to debate
does anybody wish to
debate
councillor richardson
thank you very much chair a few points
i'd like to make um in with regards to
this paper i think first as ever has to
be thanks to our section 151 officer and
the finance team for putting together
this uh document um in such a timely
manner as as as per usual um i think a
few sort of general reflections having
listened to what council dwight had said
and having read the report i think it's
absolutely fundamental that we we note
the lack of clarity that we have in
terms of our longer term financial
position because of uh the national
national government's um grant
allocation but notwithstanding that i
think council whitehead is absolutely
right in my view um that we need to put
our relative financial position in the
context of our medium-term outlook
um and i think given the fact that we've
got an increasing council tax base given
the fact that we've got increased
revenue coming from our investments
i think we have what that gives us is a
much greater degree of flexibility when
it comes to investing in our communities
both in terms of revenue but both in
terms of uh capital as well and council
white had gave gateway 14 is a very very
obvious and very welcoming example
um but what not only does it give you
that flexibility i do think
would you know notwithstanding the
context of that lack of clarity it does
give us i think as a cabinet a degree of
assurance about our medium-term
financial security
which i think is something that's very
important because although and i
completely understand um cancel the head
sort of note of caution but i think
within the context of what we're looking
at and what we're discussing now we
should put it into the context of we are
in a relatively fortuitous position
relative to some of our peers so i think
that's
absolutely right that we're prudent and
we're sensible but we shouldn't
underestimate the opportunities that we
have as a result of our financial
position
um and finally actually there's a point
um that council eben raised about social
value which i think is a very important
one and i just wanted to reiterate what
the chief executive um had said
particularly around working with
partners across the system i think
people or our residents will not make
the distinction between district and
borough or county
when it is coming to the delivering of
value for money and investing in in
social value as a concept so just to
again build on what the chief executive
said we had a meeting of the health and
well-being board on the 20th of january
where we considered social value as a as
a not just a principle but actually
something we want to deliver in in
practice and so that will cover the
periods i was just having a look at the
papers now it covers the period from
2022 to 2026 so sort of now is
absolutely the right time to be for us
to be looking at that and and what that
does just by way of context is not just
about looking at social value in the
services that we deliver ourselves um
it's also about using our our purchasing
power um as a relatively large spender
locally to actually encourage our
contractors and our suppliers to adopt
the social value principles as well
and that's for things like hiring local
people or sourcing local products
because i think that's a really
important way of delivering a whole
spectrum of different social values so
suffolk county council's health and
well-being the paper that went to it
broke it down into different social
economic and environmental benefits and
i think there's a huge amount that we
can
embed within our all aspects of our
corporate plan that follow those
principles so i think that's an
absolutely essential area that both
county and obviously artists
mid-southwark can focus on but i'm
absolutely confident that we can we can
do that going forward thank you chair
and i'm if i didn't mention it i'm very
happy to support the recommendations in
the paper thank you thank you very much
um yes the social return on value is
something that's becoming increasingly
inbuilt into our our purchasing cycle a
really good example of this is the
needham lake visitor center
where
some of the determinations were made
around what the social return
for our residents was and that was a key
key factor in in the decision making
around that so
i'm also very happy with this report i
think
councillor whitehead and
catherine and our
office have done a really good job on
this
um
there's nobody else wishes oh sorry
councillor fleming
thank you i mean just very briefly i i
just like to um
to echo what um counselor richardson has
said and counselor eben about
social value it's something we're much
more aware of now
and
just looking at the various charts in
this paper
the new homes bonus has brought in a lot
of money to the district over the years
and even though that may be leveling off
into the um future
you know we have a really good pot here
and i i feel that the original intensive
new home bonus is to um
in a way compensate communities for the
um
usually more sort of short to medium
term effects of of growth and house
building and i think um there's an awful
lot we can and should be doing with that
money to reinvest in our communities to
make sure that um the environment is um
and that the quality of life is restored
to to communities and um you know i
think there's a real agenda ahead to
look at things differently and um
proactively
you know with the fortunate amount of of
money we've got here thank you
anybody else wishes to join the debate
no in which case i'm now going to ask
the governance officer to conduct the
vote
thank you chair
members
that vote is now in progress in your
europe
councillor fleming are you able to vote
would you like me to take your vote
verbally
thank you members chair that's eight
votes for
thank you
thank you very much
so moving on now to item nine this is
the
mca 21 35
is the housing revenue account
2022-23 budget
and i'm going to invite councillor
whitehead to introduce his report
thank you madam chairman
yes i'd like to now introduce our second
budget report which covers a ring fence
to housing revenue account
and it's report mca 2135
that starts on page 81.
these last two years during the covered
pandemic they've negatively impacted our
housing revenue account
our new build program has been seriously
delayed due to lockdown measures and
social distancing
and our maintenance and repair program
has likewise been affected
in our forecasted out turn for the
present year which was brought to
cabinet in december
we set out the forecasted three-quarter
of a million pound adverse revenue
impact in 2122
and this learning experience has been
built into the budget for the new year
2223.
the 14 uplift on building services
expenditure
from the current year's budget to next
year's budget may on the face of it seem
either excessive or over prudent but i
do not believe this to be the case
i would describe it as preparing the
budget on a realistic basis
there are still backlogs to be caught up
there is without doubt a great deal of
inflationary pressure
on building materials and supplies
on the income side the government has
quite a few years now set out guidance
and limits for the year-on-year changes
to our castle house rent levels
we had five years up to march 20
and we were obliged to reduce rents in
each of those years by one percent
so a rent reduction of marginally over
five percent in that period
which has been truly challenging for our
housing revenue account
since 2020 we've been allowed to
increase rents by cpi plus one percent
leading to modest year-on-year increases
this year though
inflation has moved far above the
government's own target for cpi
leading to this proposed 4.1 rent
increase
all of us must have some concerns
regarding such an uplift
therefore therefore i feel the need to
put this into the context of our housing
revenue account
expect to start the year 2223 with hra
reserves of just under 3 million
now that might sound like a decent sized
number to most people but as we have 3
000 houses it equates to less than 1 000
pounds per house
in addition even with this 4.1 rent
increase we're only anticipating a
marginally above break-even position for
the budget this year
so this new year will add very little to
reserves
but yet we have great ambitions to
improve our castle house stock
along with upgrades and replacements to
kitchens and bathrooms when they're
needed
we must look to better insulation and
other measures
that will be needed to bring all our
housing stock in due course up to an epc
level of c
and all of this of course framed within
the context of our carbon zero
aspirations
and those certainly won't be achieved
with just one thousand pound per
dwelling
a great deal more detail putting the
meat on these bones will be coming
forward in our next 30 year hr business
plan which is due soon
but it's clear now that for the future
benefit of those our residents
remembering that this hra is a
ring-fenced account we do need to make
this 4.1 rent increase
we are proposing to keep garage rents
and shelter housing services charges
frozen at current levels and are making
modest increases to sheltered housing
utility charges which will still include
an element of cross subsidy
we have an ambitious capital program in
this budget
as i said earlier kobe has seriously
delayed our new bill program
so having total
an anticipated 2. 21.5 million capital
carry forward
along with 17.6 million of new capital
funding
over the next four years we have
identified development sites to deliver
341 new homes
a welcome increase in our housing stock
for those residents most in need of a
new house to call home
there's clearly a lot more detail in the
report than i can cover in my
introduction but i'd like to now move
the recommendations set out in section
three of our report
they're itemized in paragraphs 3.1 to
3.7
and i'll ask the cabinet member for
housing to second those recommendations
she along with myself and the finance
team and the ad for housing
we have to answer any questions that
members may have on this hra business
report but sorry budget report thank you
thank you councillor whitehead
councillor haddington
um thank you yes i'm very happy to
second this thank you
do we have any questions from cabinet
members
any questions from anybody else
counsellory bern
thank you very much chair um thank you
council whitehead for that um
just with regards to the um proposed
rent increases of 4.1
um
obviously we're all aware of the cost of
living increases that
most people are suffering from at the
moment could you just um or could
somebody let me know if there's going to
be any additional
help available to people that
may be struggling and and that um
increase might sort of tip them over as
it were um
if so if there's any anything additional
over and above what we already offer
thank you very much thank you chair
in terms of the sort of process and when
people
our tenants do do start to struggle with
uh the rent payments that you know just
ask gavin to sort of detail
you know the sort of process that
we go through and what other help might
be available
thank you chair and uh thank you
councillor eben for the question um
i think it's important to know uh all of
the the help and assistance that
officers within the housing team do
provide not only to housing tenants but
on a tenure neutral basis so we have a a
team of tenancy support
officers that provide a level of
financial inclusion and advice
and assistance to
uh to to those in in most need
part of that is about benefit
maximization
as well as looking at opportunities to
attract
possibly grants or or loans or
support into to those people
homes and that their household
bills
in addition to that we have obviously
received
over recent months additional funding
from the government both in relation to
the household support fund for which
suffolk received 5.1 million
and has been allocated to a variety of
outcomes including
food and fuel poverty
the the local welfare assistance scheme
uh and and to housing as well and in
addition to that uh baba and mid-suffolk
district councils have received uh
homelessness additional homelessness
prevention monies um towards the the
latter half of last year that have to be
spent by by march and we're fully uh on
track to spend those homelessness
prevention uh monies to support those in
greatest need as well um
in in terms of what might be be coming
forward uh clearly um everyone in the
room will will be aware of some of the
announcements last week in terms of uh
around energy and particularly the
challenges that uh that individuals will
be facing across the country in terms of
energy bills um whether that be the
additional uh
loan or or reduction in uh council tax
rates um
uh of i think a value of 150 pounds for
any home a to d from from memory so
there's some examples um but most
importantly we will continue to promote
not only our services but the services
of others including the citizens advice
bureau for whom i met with on on friday
to talk about
closer joined up working
and and know that residents can contact
officers whether they be within the
housing service
the communities team or anyone else when
looking for support
thank you
i'm now going to open it up for debate
does anybody wish to
add anything
counselor heading
thank you yes i'd just like to take this
opportunity to say thank you and well
done to all the members of the housing
and the finance team for producing the
support in what's been a very difficult
year with the rising prices of both
materials and labor so i'm thank you
well done guys
thank you
so the recommendations are before you
3.1 to 3.7 i'm now going to ask the
governance officer to conduct the vote
thank you chair members that vote is now
in progress in your app
thank you members chair that's eight
votes for
thank you very much indeed
moving on to item 10 mca
21-36
is the business rates relief policies
i'm going to invite council whitehead
again
to present his report
thank you madam chairman say for my
third report of the today
nothing like starting the week with a
bang rather than a whimper
i'm pleased to introduce the business
rates relief policies report mca 2136
which starts on page 91.
the government's recently announced
plans to provide additional business
rate support packages
the kobit 19 additional relief fund or
calf for short
and the reit and retail hospitality and
leisure discounts transitional relief
and supporting small businesses relief
as with earlier release and discounts
these four new schemes are temporary
measures
and the government is not enacting
primary legislation to bring them into
effect
instead the government's relying on
local authorities to use their
discretionary powers
granted by the localism act to grant
these release discounts and grant
payments
and granting these we as a local
authority will be fully reimbursed by
the government
so although we have the choice either to
use our discretion
it would seem nonsensical not to do so
through the four schemes we can reduce
the business rates or make grants to
local businesses that meet the criteria
at no cost to ourselves
national money for local businesses
our offices within the shared revenues
partnership are currently analyzing the
business rates
the business rates rating list data
to identify eligible cases to model
schemes and processes to be followed for
the carf scheme
the government expects local authorities
to make payments from the crf scheme in
this financial year year and toward to
award the other release and discounts to
eligible rate payers in time for the 20
new 2022-23 bills issued in march
so time is clearly of the essence
appendixes a b and c in the report set
out the proposed policies covering the
three reliefs and discounts i'd like to
move the recommendations set out in
section 3
paragraph 3.1 to 3.4
as the cars policy is still in
development 3.1 grants our id for
corporate resources in consultants in
consultation with myself
an account member for economy authority
to agree that policy
and with us today is andrew wilcock who
is the revenues operation manager in the
shared revenues partnership
and he along with myself and catherine
steele are here to answer any questions
that members may have on these four
policies thank you
thank you councillor whitehead do we
have a seconder
councillor brewster thank you madam
excuse me sorry i i had great pleasure
in on behalf of businesses in in uh
seconding this report
which will obviously give businesses
that are
getting crippled um
alive and keep keep them running
thank you
thank you councillor brewster
and do we have any questions from
cabinet members
no
questions from anybody else
no
in which case i'll open up for debate
does anybody wish to engage in debate
no
so the recommendations are 3.1 to 3.4
and i'm going to ask the governance
officer to conduct the vote
thank you chair members that vote is now
in progress
thank you chair that's eight votes force
unanimous
thank you very much
so our next item is item 11 mca
21-37 the accommodation and
agile strategy for endeavor house
unfortunately the cabinet member for
assets and investments is unable to be
here so i'm going to introduce the
report
i'm pleased to be presenting this report
today as part of our journey to deliver
truly collaborative forward-looking
workspaces for our staff and councillors
that will support them to serve our
communities and residents
we have all worked in different ways
over the last two years and have learned
many things we have taken this
opportunity to consider the best ways of
working in the future by engaging with
both staff and counsellors and listen to
what they have learned through the
pandemic
our staff
survey showed that staff believed they
could be most effective by working in a
hybrid way
with the main reasons for coming into
the office to collaborate with
colleagues and partners and for their
own well-being
our survey showed that approximately 70
percent of staff would prefer to attend
the office when they needed to and no
more than three days per week
by considering this alongside our
occupational survey prior to the
pandemic we can reduce our overall floor
space within endeavour house
and use these savings to deliver truly
collaborative and inspiring workspaces
for our organizations
whilst also delivering a net saving of
approximately
thousand
per council
and reducing our impact on the
environment by reducing travel
this project will deliver creative
flexible workspaces for staff and
as we return to more face-to-face
collaborations
it is more important that we invest in
delivering these workspaces for our
people as they continue to work hard for
our residents whether they are working
in the in the office working from home
or throughout our districts
and i'm excited to see this vision
being delivered and to see how this
supports and transforms our
organizations
as we continue to focus on serving our
residents
can i call for a seconder please
counselor richardson
uh yes chair very happy to second and
i've got a few points to make but i'll
save those for the debate
thank you very much
do we have any questions from cabinet
members
questions from anybody else
counselor
yeah thank you chair um i'm looking at
the table on
it's at paragraph 6.4
um
and it appears to me that
there is a potential
for a saving of 338
thousand
pounds
um
subject to a cost of two hundred and
fifty thousand pounds
um
now
uh
that's not a huge saving and i'm just
concerned
um i mean it's a good idea i'm not i'm
not decrying the idea at all i think
it's a i think it's a good idea but
there are one or two concerns one is we
don't know what the cost of the
dilapidations might be
and whilst i think to have the right
sort of furniture is a good idea
it could be a lot of furniture being
thrown away
for new furniture to be brought in at
cost
so i think it'd be useful to to know
what the the real cost of this is
whether there is any saving or not there
may there may be there may not be that's
not the important thing the important
thing is
that the staff have
working conditions where they can give
it their best
so that brings me on to my second
question and that is around the um
implications
of
staff working and what the financial and
environmental cost of staff working at
home
and also how are we going to check on
the health and well-being of staff who
might not be seen very often um quite
often people can get
sort of down in the dumps in their if
they're picked up if they're in the
office but they could they could well um
their well-being could deteriorate if
they don't
if they don't see their colleagues very
often
thank you councillor willam i'm i'm
going to bring in emily on this one
thank you
hey good morning everyone thank you for
those questions
um
just working through those in order the
dilapidations costs um
will be borne by the council whenever
they give up the the property so
in essence there's no uh saving or
additional cost it's more about bringing
that cost forward so rather than it
being in five years time when the lease
expires it would be this autumn when the
break is implemented
and we will work with the county council
to minimise those dilapidations
and i'm confident that we can deliver
those within within the
budget with regard to your comments
around furniture i completely agree we
need to make the best use of the
furnitures we have available and the
brief that we gave our consultants was
to make sure we recycle as much
furniture as possible so we are reusing
for example the desks um
that are within our floor plate we're
also looking to reuse storage and as
well so there will be a mixture of new
furniture and
and and retaining some of the existing
furniture that still serves a
purpose
um in terms of your comments with regard
to staff and how we can make sure that
their well-being is being protected
and
i think that's the point of this
exercise largely is about making sure we
have the right spaces for our people to
work in
and and that we're supporting their
wider well-being so for some people
working remotely works better for them
for others it doesn't we are empowering
our staff and their managers to use the
facilities that um
we have available to suit the needs of
their services and their staff
you're quite right that when people are
working remotely in the way that we have
done um over the last few years we do
need to be a bit more proactive about
making sure that people
and their well-being
are being protected and and that's part
of um
the approach we're taking to make sure
that managers are appropriately trained
in order to be able to manage staff in
this hybrid and hybrid way
and and probably focuses in on
the amount of time we've committed
and to the well-being of our staff
throughout the uh the last two years we
have committed much more time to
ensuring the well-being of our staff
than we would have done when we were
working in a more more traditional way
so i hope that helps to address some of
your concerns
yeah there's just a question about the
environmental impact of staff working at
home because
they've either
in in the winter they've got heating on
in every house that they're
that they're working in whereas if they
were all here
then
we'd be heating one building
apologies sorry i missed that one and so
in terms of the environmental benefits
it's a very challenging question to
answer um if people are coming in to
endeavor house or one single location
then yes you are heating one space
however those people have also got to
travel to that one space and they may be
doing so
from from quite some distance so i think
there's a balance really between what
those environmental impacts are in terms
of reducing travel which we've certainly
seen over the pandemic and as well as
the kind of offset of potentially houses
being needing to be heated a little bit
more and there are some other
environmental benefits that we've seen
throughout the pandemic as well
so we've seen far less printing
occurring and with people working
remotely being more and reliant on their
digital connections rather than paper
connection so i think that's an area we
will need to
look at further and review as we move
forward but certainly we can see some
environmental benefits from working in
this agile way so that we're not
bringing people into the office
unnecessarily
and if they can do things in a remote
way and that's the best way of serving
and the
businesses and service areas that they
work for then they have the flexibility
to do that whilst also understanding
that some people don't have the same
setup at home
in order to work effectively so they
have the ability to come into
endeavour house to to work so if they're
concerned about their heating they can
obviously come in and work from an
endeavor house instead
thank you very much
i'm now going to open up
this item for debate does anybody wish
to come in counselor richardson
thank you very much chair um
put simply i think this is brilliant um
i think it's absolutely right that we
consider now what our corporate
footprint looks like i think many
organizations across the country are
doing the same postcovid it seems
entirely sensible and for us to be doing
so but actually i think what this does
is gives us a real opportunity to kind
of reassess the way that we work in the
way that we deliver for our residents
and i think fundamentally this is about
getting the right balance
between
supporting our staff in terms of
flexible working and their own work life
balance and i think there are loads of
benefits for us as an organization
associated with that things like
productivity job satisfaction
recruitment and retention if we can
offer people um
the ability to work in the way that they
want to work and the way that they feel
best able to contribute i think we'll
have a much stronger workforce as a
result but also simultaneously enhancing
the benefits of working in collaboration
with our partners as you've quite
rightly said chair
and i think
looking at my portfolio i think i've got
probably the best example of that in
terms of well-being because we are
located in the building that has the ccg
which includes the chief exec designated
of the new integrated care board we've
got the public health team at suffolk
county council and we've got the
university of suffolk and the integrated
care academy not too far down the road
which i think is absolutely fantastic um
for i mean in the nhs for example we
talk a lot about the co-location of
services and i think it's absolutely
right that we apply that same thinking
to the co-location of local government
um and
as as far as i'm concerned you know for
co-locating with our health and social
care partners this could not be a better
place
for us to be based um and i
i think it's it's really important
obviously to consider not only what we
what we're currently doing but also how
we can can improve that in the future
and i think that's why it's so important
that contained within this is this new
redesign of the space that we do occupy
for it to include more collaboration
space and so i'm really pleased to see
that in foot plate design because i
think that will only enhance the way
that we can work more collaboratively
with the people
that we share this building with um in
terms of i appreciate there are some
cost savings in this um and it's right
that we shouldn't be paying for space
that we're not using but actually i
think fundamentally it's that um
value-adding aspect for the
organizational benefits we can accrue as
a result is what i think is the is the
real kind of driving force behind what
we should be doing in this in this
strategy um and then transforming the
way that we work as a result which i
think is absolutely fantastic so i'm
enthusiastically endorsing this report
thank you chair
thank you anybody else wish to come
in council delighted
thank you um
this break clause which i believe is
this autumn i think to me it just feels
perfectly timed i'd like to commend
whoever first negotiated that at the
start of the lease
um you know we've talked about our
finances earlier surpluses and the
reserves and things and i think it was
so easy to to to be a lazy council and
just keep things going on as they were
because there aren't those financial
pressures so it's it's i really do
commend
the officers for driving this forward
for looking at these operational
disciplines and the financial benefits
that come from it
and it's great that we are dynamic
council that way and i think that way so
thank you
thank you councillor whitehead
it it became
clear even before kobe titus
that
our existing
first floor was being underutilized even
pre-pandemic
the highest occupancy
on that floor was only 60 percent
and even with the reduction to half a
plate
we can still accommodate 60 of our stuff
so any any fears or worries that we
might have about
people wanting to work and not being
able to find a space
is is ill-founded
not only because we have got the space
on just half a floor plate but because
of the wider collaboration areas
um scattered throughout throughout the
building you know the ground floor the
coffee shops the coffee platforms
all the whole of the top floor
um
is all collaboration space and it's
collaboration that we are in most need
of
so
i i totally endorse this this is a
fantastic opportunity and it's going to
save us
time and effort and also contribute to
our officers well-being as well
so
um
on that note i'm going to
ask the governance officer to conduct
the vote thank you claire
thank you chair
remembers that vote is now in progress
thank you members chair that's eight
votes for
thank you
thank you very much
item 12 mca
21-38
is the haven gateway partnership
membership
and i'm going to invite councillor
brewster the cabinet member for economic
growth to introduce this report thank
you
thank you chair
yes i would like to introduce this
report in which cabinet are asked to
consider whether or not the council
should retain its membership of the
haven gateway partnership beyond the
31st of march 2022
the economic landscape has changed
significantly since the having gateway
since the haven gateway partnership was
established over 20 years ago
new economic partnerships have been set
up
such as the new anglia local enterprise
partnership
soviet growth and more recently
three-point freeport east
which have allowed our businesses to
access a range of support funding and
new opportunities to grow and innovate
the recent announcements around leveling
up could also see economic partners in
the east work more closely together
whilst i'm pleased our council has been
part of the notable successes of the
haven gateway partnership at a time when
resources needed even more scrutiny it
has been appropriate to review the
future provision of the partnership
alongside some of the other important
cross-border priorities and
collaborations
these existing and new partnerships
such as the suffolk climate change
partnership
appear to have stronger links to
businesses in our districts
provide more new opportunities for
routes into funding
and are built upon strong governance and
a united vision for the future for east
for suffolk east
and and the east
whilst the haven gateway provides a
unique link to north essex i am
confident that the strong collaboration
already developed with essex as part of
the freeport east
will continue to grow and prosper
i would therefore propose that cabinet
approved the three recommendations in
this report
to note the growth and existence of new
partnerships across suffolk and the
wider east
to withdraw from the haven gateway
partnership at the end of march 31st
this year
that delegated authority be given to the
assistant director economic development
and regeneration
and in consultation with the portfolio
holder for economic growth
to finalize
any legal documents associated with a
redraw or from the partnership
thank you chair
thank you councillor brewster and can i
have a second
counselor fleming
thank you chairman i'm happy to second
this this um this recommendation
thank you do we have any questions from
cabinet members
questions from anybody else
anybody wish to engage in debate
councillor fleming
thank you um thank you chairman i just
wanted to endorse what councillor bruce
has just said um with which i i you know
most wholeheartedly agree um you know
the funding priorities and investment
strategy of this area have definitely
changed since 2001
and with new priorities emerging and
particularly in the areas of environment
um
energy and public health
we're forming new alliances with
neighbors including um
local authorities
um counties and particularly i'm pleased
to see um you know with the freeport
east and the um
growth of energy projects and the
importance of energy to this region are
links with northeast essex
so
i think there's everything everything
about this report makes sense and i'm
happy to second it
so the um
the recommendations are 3.1 3.2 and 3.3
and i'm now going to ask the governance
officer to conduct the vote thank you
thank you chair members your vote is now
in progress
thank you members chair that's eight
votes for thank you
thank you very much everybody for your
time this morning
uh meetings finished 11 44. the next
meeting will be on this monday the 7th
of march at 10 30.
thank you members thank you
you